Oh it's so pretty
(Jack in the distance) IT'S WORKING
What?
It's working! It's working!
[Mechanical laughter]
Ow
No. NO NOO NOO NO
Nuuh Noot! Noot!
Noot?
Nooooot!
I don't know what to do!
(Screams)
Oh!
Give me dem blocks
(Excited Laughing)
Oh, don't roll! NO! oh God! AAAAH!
(Blubbering noises)
Why even bother if I know all is going to end in failure?
That's bull honkey!
I'm at it baby!
Yeah!
Umm
Let's see, what can I add?
I could add
Oh that's so cool
(Germanly) Dis is de van!
(Still Germanly) Dis is de van!
Let's blow something up here!
God blast my—
And yeah baby!!
Yeah! I'm the best
OooOh Yeah!
Oh my God!
Oh it was like 3 seconds long but it was like the best 3 seconds of my life!
just like the first time I had– Never mind!
Anyway.
(Clears throat)
Oh it's so pretty!
Ok, I can arrange objects in a solar system, but this is blowing my mind right now!
Scalpels, over on the right. Yes
You pick those up with just your forefinger and your thumb
Ok. Very delicate!
Very delicate!
Not telling to do it now
You gonna kill me?
OOOH!
RUUUN!
SWIIIM!
AAAH! I'M SCARED!